Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how easily we can
transfer our motion onto a virtual character.
And even play virtual table tennis as if we
were a character in a computer game!
Hmm!
This research work proposes to not use the
industry standard motion capture sensors to
do this.
Instead, they promise a neural network that
can perform full-body motion capture from
6 Inertial Measurement Units.
These are essentially gyroscopes that report
accelerations and orientations.
And this is the key.
This presents us with two key advantages.
Hold on to your papers for advantage number
one, which is - no cameras are needed.
Yes, that’s right.
Why is that great news?
Well, a camera is a vision-based system, and
if people are far away from the camera, it
might have some trouble making out what they
are doing, of course, because it can barely
see them.
But now with the inertial measurement units
and this neural network.
They can also be further away, maybe a room
or two away, and - no problem.
So good!
And, if it doesn’t even need to see us,
we can hide behind different objects, and
- look!
It can still reconstruct where we are.
Loving it.
Or, we can get two people to play table tennis.
We can only see the back of this player, and
the occlusion situation is getting even worse
as they turn and jump around a great deal.
Now you made me curious - let’s look at
the reconstruction together.
Wow, that is an amazing reconstruction.
In the end, if the contestants agree that
it was a good match, they can hug it out,
or…wait a second, maybe not so much.
In any case, the system still works.
And, advantage number two, ah, of course.
Since it thinks in terms of orientation and
acceleration, it doesn’t even need to see
you.
So…oh yes!
It also works in the dark.
Note that so do some infrared camera-based
motion capture systems, but here, no cameras
are needed.
And, let’s see that reconstruction.
There is a little jitter in the movement,
but otherwise, very cool.
And, if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because I
am going to tell you how quickly this runs.
And that is 90 frames per second.
Easily in real time.
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect.
I am sure you noticed that there is a bit
of a delay in the movements, and often, some
jitter too.
And, as always, do not think of this paper
as the final destination.
Think of this as an amazing leap forward,
and always, always apply the First Law of
Papers.
What is that?
Well, just imagine how much this could improve
just two more papers down the line.
I am sure there will be no delays and no jitter.
So, from now on, we are one step closer to
be able to play virtual table tennis, or even
work out with our friends in a virtual world.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!